que jordi vera coordinateur du mouvement
oui aux pays acp catalan bonsoir jordi
vera
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france perpignan est elle devenue la la
base arrière des indépendantistes
catalans mais cela provoque à l'espagne
a pas de liberté puisque les trois
président catalan pour pouvoir
s'adresser à la population seront
obligés devlies la terre clients pour
pouvoir s'exprimer librement
puisque le plus en plus de monde ne peut
pas rentrer en espagne et que deux
autres présidents ont été destitués l'un
il ya quelques temps un intéressement
alors il ya eu cette visite du roi
d'espagne et du premier ministre
aujourd'hui très mal accueillis on l'a
vu par des manifestants c'est cette une
ligne franchie on n'est pas loin
évidemment de on est à quelques jours en
tout cas de l'anniversaire de ce
référendum confisqué et coûté en tout
cas sur le divorce au total entre la
monarchie et les catalans est par contre
assez politique sur l'ensemble de la
population catalogne il faut savoir
qu'il ya une trentaine d'années la cata
dès la 4' était la région la plus loyale
ici tempère de la monarchie est
aujourd'hui les quatre ans comme ceux
qui n'ont plus de loi puisque en six ans
de règne de l'actuel roi espagnol
trois présidents ont été destitués m6
entre président et franchement 2500
personnes sont poursuivies jeudi divers
dans les instances publiques espagnoles
des prisonniers politiques peuple les
pigeons des exilés en fait on n'est plus
un pays démocratique on est dans une
juste mesure tout à fait loin et vous
dites aussi que cette situation a été
aggravée par les mesures de restrictions
sanitaires
oui en effet parce que aujourd'hui la
catalogne demandé il ya plusieurs mois
des plans de certaines décisions
le pouvoir central a refusé de prendre
c'est toutes ces décisions et ça peut
moquer l'arrondissement de la patte de
vie puisque c'est à partir de madrid que
c'était pas de vie s'est étendue dans
toute l'espagne
à partir du moment où il n'y avait pas
de confinement et les milliers de
voitures quitter madrid pour aller se
réfugier un peu partout dans toute
l'espagne
troquant les factures une fiction des
milliers de personnes pourtant pourtant
l'espagnol n'a pas un gouvernement
central en matière de santé ce ne sont
pas les régions qui dessine ça l'était
mais pire à l'état d' alerte qui a été
décrété le voir centre après toutes les
compétences de la santé et donc toutes
les mesures qui ont été décidées
j'étais laissé par la ministre de la
santé espagnole et vous avez à juste
titre les gens pour dire qu'il n'avait
pas d'administration de la santé en
espagne avait pas du tout et que en fait
on imposer à aux autorités sanitaires
avaient des régions d autonomie en ce
qui concerne l'espagne on impose des
mesures qui n'étaient pas à partager un
parler par les gouvernements régionaux
puisque on demandait le traitement
différencié de ce qui nous était région
puisqu'elle a pas de vie n'était pas la
même partout
est ce ce refus systématique il a été
rendu obligatoire ces jours ci puisque
hier
madrid a dû être confinés et si mal et
avait été confié à plusieurs mois
peut-être évité c'était pas de viger
pandémie généralisée en espagne alors il
y as
cette réunion un perpignan avec les
trois anciens leaders indépendantistes
et ils ont signé le manifeste de
perpignan qu'est-ce que ça symbolise
qu'est ce que ça représente se
manifestent aujourd'hui dans cette cause
indépendantiste sur le mans c'est un
appel à la communauté internationale et
l'union européenne de se demander
qu'elle s'engage à favoriser des
négociations et discussions parce qu'il
est évident que dans le tête à tête
entre les catalans et l'espagne a pas de
sortie puisque le pouvoir central refusé
toute discussion est la preuve en est
que tous les présidents élus par la
population 4 ans sont destitués à terol
et que finalement c'est impossible de
négocier quoi que ce soit et la paradoxe
de cette explication c'est que le moment
politique catalan mouvements
indépendantistes catalans et pacifiste
prendre la démocratie les élections et
il n'a pas peur des élections d'ailleurs
puisque toutes les élections qui ont été
convoqués et j'en étais lundi par les
indépendantistes est donc aujourd'hui
c'est un appel
selon m qui est adressé à la cour
internationale et à l'union européenne
en particulier pour que prédécesseur
discussions entre entre la catalogne et
madrid
parce que en effet c'est une situation
qui ne peut pas changer encore dans
quelques mois et de nouvelles sélections
81 de nouveau les indépendantistes avons
gagné ces élections d'après les sondages
pour après le foie sans doute à la barre
de 50 1% des voix sera franchie par
l'indépendantiste et il n'est pas
possible de continuer dans une situation
dans laquelle la volonté système
systématique dans la durée et de
l'assistance constante ne ne peux pas
comment elle ne peut pas continuer dans
une situation dans laquelle il se moque
âge dans un système où kristen
démocratique car la démocratie a parlé
et qui en a parlé à plusieurs reprises
et que la majorité des 14 s'est dégagé
pour qu'ils aient un référent dépendance
et de pouvoir se réaliser
après on se souviendra bien de
l'assister ya quelques semaines il ya
une semaine exactement en affirmant
après faire de nouvelle calédonie et que
je cherche sow n'a pas provoqué la crise
de régime en france
merci beaucoup jordi vera d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur rt
france